♪
>> BUSINESSES ALL ACROSS AMERICA
STRUGGLING TO FIND WORKERS BUT
THEY AREN'T GETTING SYMPATHY
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
CHECK OUT THIS EXCHANGE WITH A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
>> HOW DO YOU AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO
INCENTIVIZE THOSE THAT HAVEN'T
RETURNED TO WORK YET?
>> TWO THINGS, ONE, YOU NOTICE,
WE KEPT YOU OPEN.
AND I THINK IT REALLY IS A
MATTER OF PEOPLE DECIDING NOW
THAT THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
DO OTHER THINGS, AND THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OF EMPLOYEES.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO MAKE MORE
MONEY AND TO BARGAIN.
AND SO I THINK YOUR BUSINESS,
AND THE TOURIST BUSINESS, IS
REALLY GOING TO BE IN A BIND FOR
A LITTLE WHILE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS, WE'RE
ENDING ALL THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
THE THINGS KEEPING PEOPLE BACK
FROM GOING BACK TO WORK, ET
CETERA.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> IT WAS SO NICE OF HIM TO SAY
WE KEPT YOU OPEN.
WASN'T THAT PLEASANT.
YO, IT'S KIND OF WEIRD, I AM A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER, THAT I
KNOW MORE ABOUT ECONOMICS THAN
AN 80 YEAR OLD PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IF YOU PAY MORE PEOPLE YOU HAVE
TO RAISE ALL THE SALARIES AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO START LETTING
GO WORKERS SO YOU CAN AFFORD THE
HIGHER SALARIES OR YOU INCREASE
THE PRICE OF YOUR PRODUCT WHICH
THEN INCREASES INFLATION AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE.
DID I JUST EXPLAIN ECONOMICS
101.
>> YES.
>> I THINK I DESERVE A NOBEL
PRIZE.
>> I HAVE A TEN PAGE ARTICLE
FROM THE WALL STREET JOURNAL I
PLAN TO READ IN ITS ENTIRETY
THROUGHOUT THE SEGMENT ABOUT HOW
MUCH THE GOODS ARE GOING UP IN
PRICE, COMPANIES ARE HAVING TO
RAISE ALL THESE PRICES.
INFLATION CLEARLY WILL BECOME A
HUGE ISSUE FOR THE WHITE HOUSE,
BUT JOE BIDEN KEEPS COMING OUT
ANDSATION WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
MORE MONEY SO THAT'S GOING TO
HELP INFLATION, AND ACTUALLY
PEOPLE'S WAGES, WHEN ADJUSTED
FOR INFLATION, ARE GOING DOWN.
THEY'RE DOWN IN THE MOST RECENT
MONTHS AND DOWN OVER THE LAST
YEAR.
BUT THAT IS THE ONE THING THAT I
WROTE DOWN.
WE KEPT YOU OPEN.
OH, HE'S SUCH A BENEVOLENT KING
AND THAT BUSINESS OWNER IS JUST
SOME PLEBE.
THAT IS THE IING THIS OF
SOMEBODY THAT HAS BEEN IN
POLITICS FOR FIVE DECADES.
IT'S AWFUL.
>> DEFINITELY IT'S ONLY
SOMETHING, JESSICA, A DEMOCRAT
WOULD SAY, BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE IN THE POWER OF BIG
GOVERNMENT, AND THAT THAT TRUMPS
ANYTHING LIKE SMALL BUSINESS.
MEANWHILE, WHO MADE A LOT OF
MONEY DURING -- BECAUSE OF
BIDEN?
BIG BUSINESS.
ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
SHOULD HE BE IMPEACHED?
>> THAT'S TOMORROW'S SHOW.
I ALREADY GOT THE TOPIC LIST.
NO, HE SHOULDN'T BE IMPEACHED.
SO HIS ANSWER WAS ACTUALLY, HE
TALKED FOR TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES.
>> RIGHT.
>> IN BIDEN STYLE.
>> BIDEN STYLE.
>> LIKE GANG AM STYLE.
>> BUT THERE WAS ACTUALLY A LOT
OF SENTIMENT TALITY ABOUT IT.
HE TALKED ABOUT HIS
FATHER-IN-LAW OF HIS DECEASED
WIFE WAS A RESTAURANT OWNER IN
SYRACUSE AND WANTED TO SAVE THE
BUSINESS AND GOD LOVE YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DO.
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT NOT THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES AREN'T
STRUGGLING, THAT GENTLEMAN OWNED
39 RESTAURANTS.
NOT A MOM AND POP SHOP ON THE
CORNER, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN GETTING
WIPED OUT BY AMAZON.
IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF THING.
THE INFLATION ISSUE IS
DEFINITELY BECOMING A POLLING
NIGHTMARE FOR DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE, THEIR
GROCERIES COST MORE.
I'VE SEEN A LOT ON LINE,
MANDELL'S BEEN TWEETING ABOUT
THE PRICE OF DIAPERS.
SHE JUST HAD HER FIFTH CHILD
LAST WEEK AND SHE WAS LIKE OH,
MY GOD I'VE ONLY TAKEN' YEAR AND
A HALF OUT OF THIS GAME AND THE
PRICES ARE SO EXORBITANT.
THESE ARE THINGS PEOPLE NEED.
AND IF THAT CONTINUES INTO AN
ELECTION YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
PROBLEM.
HE SAID WE HAVE AN ECONOMIST,
SEVERAL SAYING THIS IS
TEMPORARY.
THAT IS MY HOPE BUT THERE
DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE A BACKUP
PLAN TO THIS IF IT ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT IS TEMPORARY AND
YOU WANT TO STAY IN POWER.
>> DID YOU JUST CITE A REAL
HOUSEWIFE.
>> STEPHANIE MANDELL.
>> IS SHE A REAL HOUSEWIFE?
>> NO.
>> THAT'S BETHENNY FRANKEL.
>> MANDELL IS A WONDERFUL WRITER
WHO HAS FIVE CHILDREN STAY AT
HOME MOTHER.
>> OH, STEPH MENDELL.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE.
>> SHE IS A PERSON WHO KNOWS A
LOT ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PRICE OF
DIAPERS BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BABY.
>> YOU HAVE A BABY.
>> THEY'RE PROBABLY UP.
>> HE LIED OUT OF THE GATE, HE
SAID WE KEPT YOU OPEN.
BIDEN'S PARTY KEPT RESTAURANTS
CLOSED.
>> BUT THEY GOT PPP LOANS.
>> NOT ONLY LAST YEAR BUT INTO
THIS YEAR.
AND THAT WAS A TRUMP PROGRAM
THAT BAILED OUT THE RESTAURANTS,
NOT HIM.
AND THEN TO SAY THAT WE KEPT YOU
OPEN, DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS WERE
ARRESTING RESTAURANT OWNERS WHO
TRIED TO OPEN AND FINING THEM.
AND THEN YOU SPELLED IT OUT
PERFECTLY, THAT'S WHY WE HAD THE
$200 FRIES, BECAUSE YOU'RE
COMPETING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S $300 FAKE BONUS SO
YOU HAVE TO RAISE WAGES, PASS IT
ON TO THE CUSTOMERS, RAISE
PRICES THAT'S WHY THINGS ARE SO
EXPENSIVE.
THEN HE SAID THE FUNNIEST THING,
SPENDING $6 TRILLION WILL NOT
INCREASE DEFLAILINGS IT WILL
DECREASE INFLATION.
THEN HE CITED MOODY'S.
NEVER CITE MOODIES, YOU KNOW
THIS.
IT IS A LEFT WING ORGANIZATION,
MARK IS A LEFT WING GUAIDO NATES
TO THE CLINTONS AND DEMOCRATS.
HE PREDICTED TRUMP WOULD SINK
THE ECONOMY INTO A RECESSION IN
2018 AND DESTROY THREE AND A
HALF MILLION JOBS AND PREDICTED
BARACK OBAMA'S RECOVERY WOULD BE
THE HOTTEST ON RECORD.
SO NEVER LISTEN TO A DEMOCRAT
WHEN THEY CITE MOODY.
THAT'S A WARNING.
>> THERE YOU GO.
KATIE IT SEEMS TO ME THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS MORE ABOUT
THE WOKE THAN THE WORK.
>> I THINK THAT'S TRUE.
THAT WAS A GOOD ONE GREG.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AS SOMEONE WHO GREW UP IN A
SMALL BUSINESS, RESPONSES LIKE
THIS FROM POLITICIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN GETTING PAYCHECKS FROM
TAXPAYERS SIGNING THE BACK OF
THEM RATHER THAN SIGNING THE
FRONT OF THEM THEIR ENTIRE LIVES
FOR 30, 40 YEARS IS REALLY
ENRAGING AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE WAY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS IMPORTING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
AKA CHEAP FOREIGN LABOR WHICH
OBVIOUSLY SUPPRESSES THE WAGES
OF AMERICAN WORKERS AT A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE SHOULD BE GOING BACK
TO WORK.
AND THEN YOU HAD THEM SAYING
THAT IT'S A WORKER'S MARKET.
WELL, WHY IS IT A WORKER'S
MARKET.
YOU WOULD THINK AFTER A PANDEMIC
WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE LOST THEIR
JOBS PEOPLE WOULD BE CLAMORING
TO GET BACK TO WORK BACK INTO
THE LABOR FORCE.
INSTEAD THEY'RE COMPETING WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO IS
PAYING PEOPLE WITH HARD EARNED
TAXPAYER DOLLARS NOT TO GO BACK
TO WORK.
AND THEN THEY HAVE THE NERVE TO
SAY, YOU NEED TO PAY 15 DLARGS
AN HOUR, NO MATTER WHICH CITY
YOU LIVE IN, NO MATTER WHAT
ECONOMIC SITUATION YOUR TOWN MAY
BE IN.
IT'S JUST SUCH A NAIVE ELITEEST
ARGUMENT TO MAKE.
>> AND THE GOVERNMENT CAN AFFORD
THIS.
>> RIGHT.
>> ABOUT YOU THE PEOPLE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS COMPETING AGAINST
CAN'T.
>> EXACTLY.
>> YOU JUST RAISED YOUR PRICES,
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT POLICY IS ENDING AND HE
CITED THAT.
>> BUT GUESS WHAT HE ADMITTED IT
FINALLY SO FOREVER THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS SAYING THIS HAS NO
IMPACT ON PEOPLE GOING BACK TO
WORK, THE UNEMPLOYMENT AND THEN
BIDEN ADMITS FINALLY YESTERDAY
THAT YEAH WE'RE ENDING THOSE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE IT'S PREVENTING
PEOPLE TO GO BACK TO WORK.
>> EXCEPT ALL THESE NEW
ENTITLEMENTS HE WANTS TO PUSH
THROUGH ARE NOT BASED ON WORK.
YOU CAN COLLECT WITH NO WORK
REQUIREMENT.
MY PARENTS WERE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND YOU G